ねえ君はもう友達じゃない
友達より大事な人
どう
じゃないんよ美味しい熱いでござるな
どうですかこのうちは問題ありでしょ
耳おかしい子だって打ち合ってそのままオーグもんなんだよ猫の耳がおかしいんであり
ません
辛く茶でなんか気持ち悪い
ますてる通り私はローソンに努めさせて頂いておりましては基本的にはローソンの商品
は基本的に何でも知っていますまあ今まで動画でおすすめの商品をチョイスに取り上げ
てきたんですけど最近とんでもなくこれは来てるってもう商品があったんでまぁ見て
お主らにちょっ
だけん
お星様与党も
大君たちは友達じゃない加藤チョコレートドリンクです
こういう年ちょっとです
佐藤さと惜しいものをたくさん生んだねぇ
脂肪をつけようと思う
商業であります
まあこれどんな人におすすめかというとまあチョコ好きですね
ものすごいチョコの味がするんですよ
とりあえず飲んでみたら分かりますチョコ好きの方いただきます
ああ何ていうんがあれそこの有名な会社
なんちゃってばだけやれ
ベルガモットぞれ
アロハロ
こっち箱水は言葉のチョコを無駄にした感じですね
甘いんですけどちょっとに外観図本陣に何か
そこの高級そうなチョコの味がするドリンクです
デブはやめといた方がいいでしょ
美味しい
東大後ぶりもの向かい
燃料もごプリン最近ダイエットしてるからな
ゴブリンそんなこと言っちゃダメだよこれじゃ
フォースの力が扱えないんだ
うーんなんでそんなこと言うのジャンゴム
わかったじゃあ君も飲むねー
f 2
うーんおいしい
ゴブリン慌てちゃダメだよそんなにのんなホラ話が出てきたっちゃじゃないか
これはゴブリン飲み過ぎてつ難関
毛穴のケア何穴と言う穴からチュッ
それの見過ぎて
家だけは出さないようにしてくださいねダウンオーバーされました
ぜひねお店で確認していただけたらありがたいと思います
というわけだ
飲んでみてください喰霊チョコレートドリンクでした
じゃあな
me
wh